so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
happy
happy hump day
[Music]
11 central nine
pacific you know what time that is
it's time for let's talk the tony
michaels podcast here every single
weekday
oh and the things we have to talk about
today
we have um kevin mccarthy trying to be
forrest gump i don't know if you've seen
this
it's [ __ ] this [ __ ] guy runs runs
and runs and runs he runs fast i mean
super fast like super super super duper
fast
away from reporters when they're asking
him about you know like a violent
insurrection
uh yesterday you've seen
not not only kevin mccarthy scurry away
from a reporter a reporter in the
capitol that was questioning him but you
also seen
mitch mcconnell
the uh the minority turtle i mean leader
in the senate come out and basically
admit uh yeah it was a violent
insurrection we're not going to call it
uh
legitimate political discourse
it seems like a lot of news is gonna be
dropping
uh
and i i don't think it's just gonna be
on one person in particular and i think
i think this is all you know the cards
are starting to to fall here
uh
it really it really does seem like uh
little by little that we tick by as we
see the trickle trickle trickle out into
the media
of some of the evidence not just not
just at january 6 but in the lead up to
it every single attempt these [ __ ]
seditious traders tried to make
to try to take machines
to try to make other people take
machines to try to find boats and
couches and beds wherever they can find
them
and
stop the steel you remember this [ __ ]
stop to stop the steal stop the steal
cause it was first stop the count like
stop counting votes like yeah okay
democracy and [ __ ]
but it was stop the steal well that was
all 100 projection all of it
the whole [ __ ] time of course it was
because they're [ __ ] fascist
these [ __ ] republicans and that's why
kevin mccarthy is scurrying away from
reporters
oh my god
how are you guys this morning everyone
says hello hello hello hey mj how are
you
uh patty you were the first here patty
was the first here
hello
let's see who else we got we got in here
uh hello good morning brent uh good
morning robin
good morning yoda we're all here
we're all here
it's fantastic thanks for joining us
here on wednesday
noon eastern 11 central on the tony
michaels podcast oh look we got mayo
here good morning mayo everyone say good
morning to mayo
good morning good morning good morning
let's kick today's ass shall we
we've got a lot of things to go through
on the [ __ ] list we've got of course
kevin mccarthy uh running away from
reporters but we also have um an article
that was released on jared kushner
there's jared kushner news cory bush is
trending i'm not sure why um crack is
crack is
trending so is dejoy and the usps i
don't know if those things have to do
with each other
dolly parton and trevor noah are
trending
don't say gay i guess was trending this
morning i'm not sure why that is harvard
mark and marco rubio
now there might be some other stuff
there might be some other stuff
that's trending by now
and i guess we'll we'll see as we go
through the shitless roundup i believe
that gabe is going to join us in the
second half of the first hour i know you
guys love gabe sanchez the executive
producer and co-host here at the tony
michaels podcast
so he'll be joining us i think in the
second second half of the first hour
about uh oh 12 30 eastern 9 30 pacific
if you're watching your clock there
if you're watching your clock
so you guys see the statement from from
mitch mcconnell yesterday
very important very [ __ ] important
that that mitch mcconnell made the the
uttered the [ __ ] turtle words that he
uttered yesterday
mitch mcconnell does not go in front of
a microphone
and say anything without intent
at all not one [ __ ] word will
he'll he say i mean he won't talk at all
if he doesn't have intent
he's not [ __ ] dumb that's why that
vile piece of [ __ ] is still the minority
leader and still somehow works his way
into a state like kentucky
and wins for those [ __ ] people i have
no clue why he doesn't work for them
he doesn't work for the people of state
of kentucky
he doesn't work for the american people
as a minority leader in the senate
either
but yesterday he made sure to come out
and have the stance that mike pence had
for all attentive purposes mitch
mcconnell has given a big [ __ ] you to
donald trump and the rnc
yesterday
now
mitch mcconnell just doesn't take sides
either
he waits to see what side he should be
on
to maintain his power
because he never says anything without
[ __ ] without power
i mean that that's his whole [ __ ]
thing he doesn't care about anything
else but power
i mean yeah maybe money
but in some circles money is power
especially in politics why do you think
he's the [ __ ] king ding-a-ling in the
senate for these [ __ ] gq peers
and he plays footsie with these [ __ ]
rubes
that's what it's about
that's what it's about it's about power
what do you think uh liz cheney's been
doing well robin says it here mitch
stands with lids
well what liz cheney's trying to do is
get the party back that's what dick
cheney wants that's why darth vader
showed up on january 6 to commemorate
the people who had died on that day to
remember the people who died to remember
the tragedy that happened
and stood there with nancy pelosi
and to celebrate the continuum of our
democracy darth vader dick cheney
came to celebrate the continuum of our
democracy think about it for a second
think about it
think about what kind of [ __ ]
symbolism that is everyone kind of
breezed over that and misses that
the only republican member of the house
that showed up on january 6 a year
after the violent insurrection happened
where they tried to overthrow our
constitution
only one
only one republican member of the house
showed up
and not only that
she brought
darth vader with her to the floor he
flew all the way from wyoming
to stand next to her
in solidarity with nancy pelosi are you
[ __ ] listening to the words that i'm
saying
this is significant
it was a it's it's more significant now
possibly than it was then
because mike pence wasn't the first one
to give a big middle finger to donald
trump
as far as party power goes
i mean liz cheney they stripped her of
her of her leadership assignment
totally stripped her
and if you're of the mind that
dick cheney doesn't know what liz cheney
knows get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
and the question is
is
how
how
how is this stuff leaking out
little by little by little
and this is this is the the
the bet that the republicans took
about the january 6th select committee
right
democrats wanted a non-partisan
non-political as much as possible 911
style commission that's what they wanted
they passed it to the house they
couldn't get it through the senate
couldn't do it republicans didn't want
that type of investigation they didn't
want it
they wanted it to be political that's
what they wanted
because they thought in the political
arena they could cause chaos and they
could convince the country of what they
were hearing just wasn't true
as opposed to a non-partisan 911 style
commission where they would have to eat
the [ __ ] sandwich
well
i'm beginning to think even though it's
taking a little longer because of the
january 6th select committee
and how that's a political investigation
because it is it's political don't let
anyone tell you it isn't that's what the
republicans wanted that's what they
wanted they wanted this political fight
inside the select committee
they're losing
i don't know if you noticed kevin
mccarthy can't even answer your question
in the [ __ ] hallway he's running away
from reporters
mitch mcconnell has to come out and
basically say oh yeah the former guy
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy he tried
to overturn our government
it's un-american
was the word that mike pence used un
american you're not a [ __ ] patriot in
other words
now let's not give these [ __ ] these
[ __ ] thin veiled fascists too much
goddamn credit
that [ __ ] homophobe from indiana mike
pence is no [ __ ] sweetheart here just
like i speak out against liz cheney but
listen when they got the shovel in their
hands and they're digging the grave of
trumpism fascism with a manga hat on let
them [ __ ] do it
don't take the shovel out of their
goddamn hand
let them dig that [ __ ] grave [ __ ]
them
we just gotta make sure they don't turn
that shovel around on us
that's all we got to do
but shit's coming
something's coming mitch mcconnell does
not go out in front of a microphone and
basically tell the former guy that
cheated us mobster
grandpa poopy pants himself the orange
mussolini jesus
to go [ __ ] himself
without knowing that he's on the right
side
because mitch mcconnell doesn't care
about size he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
doesn't care if he's on the bad side the
evil side the good side he doesn't give
a [ __ ] as long as he retains power
that's all he gives a [ __ ] about that's
it that's the only thing he gives a [ __ ]
he gives not a [ __ ] about anything else
not a [ __ ]
a single one
every single move every single word is
to maintain his power and that's the
reason why is because they don't work
for the american people
they don't
they won't
they couldn't how could they
their entire [ __ ] game is to maintain
power for themselves
to oppress the views of their [ __ ]
special little donors that they have on
us
the people
i mean really if you took the people of
kentucky each one of them and surveyed
them on what mitch mcconnell has done
and not done for them the [ __ ] list
would be really [ __ ] short
and the [ __ ] that people in kentucky
want done is not [ __ ] that mitch
mcconnell is interested in even [ __ ]
talking about
you think people in kentucky don't want
their kids to start school at the age of
three instead of five
not one [ __ ] parent you show me one
[ __ ] parent go out there [ __ ]
survey him bring him here i'll have him
on the show one [ __ ] parent one
just one show me that doesn't want their
kids or a grandparent that doesn't want
their grandkids to start school at three
instead of five
go get them bring them on here i'll
[ __ ] talk to them
not [ __ ] one of them
not one of them not one of them could
give a good reason why their kids
education their public schools public
education should stop at a high school
diploma
they should get two years of trade
school or our associate's degree
not [ __ ] one
show them to me [ __ ]
i bet if you talk to most people in
kentucky reasonable decent people they
would understand that they want to vote
they want to vote
they would understand hey yeah voting
yeah that's a good thing i'd want to
vote
that sounds good we'll vote for the
people that represent us you know
they're in power
you think mitch mcconnell wants those
people he doesn't want even people to
vote for him he just
the senate did we didn't use to vote for
senators did you know that we didn't use
to vote for senators we changed that
[ __ ]
we
changed that [ __ ]
we made the country better mitch
mcconnell wants to go back to the days
where he's just a [ __ ] senator he is
just the senator he doesn't need to have
an election he doesn't want votes he
didn't want to have to work for votes
what are you [ __ ] kidding me
he just wants to be the senator that's
it he just wants to have power why
should he have to work for it
but let these [ __ ]
eat each other let's draw wedges in
between them let's keep drawing wedges
in between them anytime a republican is
friend of a reporter hey you hear this
press you hear this beat reporters out
there
ask them
ask them are you on mitch mcconnell's
side or you on donald trump's side
because obviously there's two sides here
there's two sides are you are you a
bullsider are you one sider what side
are you on let's drive wedges between
them [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
continue continue continue to beat these
son of a [ __ ] to death
it's enough of this [ __ ]
this fascist [ __ ] outright fascist
steve bannon trader tv [ __ ]
gonna make donald trump the speaker of
the house [ __ ] they're raising money
off this [ __ ] matt gatz marjorie taylor
green joe kent that [ __ ] that running in
washington's third
and [ __ ] fascist yeah he's a [ __ ]
fascist goddamn nazi
wanting donald trump to be speaker of
the house so he can pardon your dumb
asses get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
mitch mcconnell does not speak into a
microphone without knowing exactly what
he's saying and why he is saying it
he didn't wait he everyone's like oh why
did he wait a whole [ __ ] year to say
this well he waited a whole year to say
this until he was sure that he was on
the side that he needed to be on to
maintain power
that's why that is exactly why it's not
[ __ ] rocket science mitch mcconnell
waited this long to say what he said
yesterday to make sure that it was the
right position so he could maintain
power
now liz cheney figured this out months
ago
months ago liz cheney figured this out
because she wants to maintain power in
the house she wants to be the speaker
it's not [ __ ] hard to understand this
they want their thin veiled fashion
fascism back they want that back they
want the old brand gop
deficits debt tea party all that thin
bailed fascism they don't like this
outright fascism people are on to them
they don't wanna look like nazis
they want to do nazi [ __ ] without
looking like nazis
so
my suggestion is to all you
pro-democracy people out there we're
gonna have to deal with this there's no
you know you can't just hide your eyes
and go oh well there's no such thing as
mitch mcconnell
nope there's sure as hell is oh there's
no such thing as donald trump there's no
such thing as these seditious [ __ ] that
are members of congress already nope we
gotta deal with it we gotta look at it
we gotta see it
if you hide yourself from what is
happening you won't see it coming when
it happens
and fascism is at the front [ __ ] door
it's here it's here they're knocking
they're ready to come on in
and take the [ __ ] over
that's what they're ready to do
so the question is do we do we put on
the boxing gloves and take the fight to
them or do we just not answer the front
door and let them come in the back
because they will they don't give a [ __ ]
they know their ideas suck
they know that we know that their ideas
[ __ ] suck cause they ain't got one
what idea do they have what policy what
are they running on give me give me
you got these [ __ ] running the
donald trump's gonna be speaker or some
[ __ ] that's what they're running on
and here we are debating why mitch
mcconnell waited this long to say this
[ __ ] well he waited this long because he
wanted to see if there was actual
evidence that was going to bury these
son of a [ __ ]
and maybe that's what we're getting to
you know i'm not
i'm not i'm not a conspiracy theorist
but i'm just snowballing here
there there are there are 11 members of
the oath keepers
that are charged with sedition
conspiracy to commit sedition we
interviewed tasha adams and dakota adams
the the estranged wife and the strange
son of stuart rhodes the leader the
founder of the [ __ ] oath keepers that
is charged with seditious conspiracy
right here on this show
an hour and 16 minutes
and yeah the eye patch thing is all cool
right the story of the eye patch is you
know
fantastic everyone loves that story but
the story that is had in that interview
is who he is what the oath keepers were
what they what they are and what they
aren't
and why the motivations of why they did
what they did and it was protect asses
from federal prosecutions
that's the assumption made go watch it
it's on the youtube channel subscribe to
the youtube channel
don't forget that while you're here
hell go re-watch that interview if you
can
it's episode 69 it's in the very first
part of that episode
here's the thing
stuart rhodes went and actually
testified for six
hours
six hours now he didn't say anything up
from january 5th on
because that's kind of what his trial is
about in federal court
and i'm sure the january 6 select
committee did not want to step on the
toes of the prosecutors in his criminal
prosecution to make sure stewart rhodes
ends up in a federal prison somewhere
but stuart rhodes is trying
his [ __ ] damndest
to get leniency when this when a federal
magistrate sentences sentence him to a
federal prison wherever that may be
shit's coming
i don't know what stewart rhodes said i
don't know what he knows but i know he
knows a hell of a lot about seditious
conspiracy and who he was conspiring
with
and if you don't think that the january
6 select committee one of their aims
especially liz cheney and adam kinzinger
aim is to make sure that there's a list
of members of congress who had anything
absolutely anything to do with the
seditious conspiracy of the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup attempt
they'll end up on a [ __ ] expulsion
list
on the floor of the house
their goal is not to just convince the
american people that trumpism is bad
that's not that's not just their goal
their goal
is to cut the head off the snake
and the snake is in the house
it's in there fascism is here they're
here
so
shall we start the shitless roundup
well let's see we got some comments here
everyone's saying hello kaelyn's here
she's late
and she was rage tweeting nazis oh
yoda says uh
said 69
[Laughter]
yeah it's episode 69 i didn't plan that
and just the way it happened yoda the
episode is episode number 69
69er
is the episode number here on youtube
so go check it out i actually um i want
to bring decode on in the next couple
weeks
i know you guys really like to go to
what he had to say and i think i think
what he says about militias
and some of the insight he has probably
into the bundy ranch and some of the
other things is probably very valuable
insight into the lead up
the lead up to january 6 and the mindset
of stuart rhodes
in when he committed this seditious
conspiracy
so let's let's get into
the [ __ ] list roundup
you guys know that um
kevin mccarthy
was forrest gump yesterday so um
we'll probably talk about that
but
but
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's no forrest gump is he let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome to the shitless roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the journey trends as you know
let's see here what do we got oh
to start off we got the bonehead of the
week poll you guys know we do the
bonehead of the week bowl
um
that's one thread i want to go to is
this brian suave
i guess
let's zoom in here oh my god this
[ __ ] guy he [ __ ] around and found
out um who's the bone end of the week
contestants brian suave i guess he's a
pastor and some i don't know who knows
where this [ __ ] guy's from but um he
he put out a tweet and there's there's
like almost 20 000 quote tweets of this
dumb [ __ ] um
demeaning women what a dumb [ __ ] what a
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] bonehead i'll show
i'll show you i'll show you this guy
[ __ ] idiot of course kevin mccarthy
made the list
he made the list
so go go
go vote for kevin if you think he won
the race
[Laughter]
as fast as he ran also jared kushner is
on the list
um this week so go vote for bonehead
that we go to at tonymichaelspod
and follow us while you're over there at
tonymichaelspod and do your vote who
should i vote for who do you guys want
me to vote for i really want to vote for
this brian guy but kevin mccarthy is
definitely a coward
for sure which makes him a complete
[ __ ] bonehead and then jared kushner
thinking he can get away with a bunch of
[ __ ] crime well that's boneheaded as
well so i'm kind of torn myself
everyone's always like oh you should put
a oh the above button yeah but then we
wouldn't if
it would always be all of the above
would [ __ ] win like every time
like every [ __ ] time all the above
would win
that's why we don't put the button there
because we know what you would do all
the above
like all because really honestly this is
sometimes hard to choose like me and
gabe have talked about it's really
[ __ ] hard to choose it sometimes
right
like it's totally hard to choose like
who to even put on this list because a
lot of times like we'll wait like we
were like on monday we're like okay
there's these three yeah but there's
going to be something else coming right
there's got to be something else coming
there's going to be there's going to be
more [ __ ] happening
and and then here we are this brian
suave so if we would have done the poll
on monday this guy would have never made
it on the list that's why we came up
with the dishonorable mention when we do
the bone head of the week and now we do
the bone end of the week in the in the
second hour
every single week
on fridays on fridays the second hour is
where bonehead lives
bone end of the week we go through the
list right
well
you know
it's kind of hard
the reason why is because we got to
figure out okay who's the bone in gonna
be but we we came up with the
dishonorable mention
because there's always another bonehead
like that comes along that's even more
boneheaded than the [ __ ] three we got
on the list and now we got alpha cuck of
the week because we gotta have these
alpha cups because we're gonna talk
about alpha cucks today when gabe when
gate comes in the chat here
uh the reason why is because you've seen
yesterday well there's been a
progression over this week with joe
rogan uh these right-wing alpha cucks
are blaming it on the mizella's brothers
uh ben brett and jordy they some kind of
[ __ ] conspiracy theory they think of
some kind of cabal which you know it's
got all kinds of anti-semitic tropes to
just just the way that they present the
quote unquote evidence that oh my god
you retweeted something that means you
did it like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about there's
thousands of people that retweet [ __ ]
every [ __ ] day that doesn't mean they
have anything to do with the [ __ ]
video posted you dumb [ __ ]
these [ __ ] goddamn
fragile white males it's ridiculous
and now they they brought uh dave
portnoy because dave portnoy entered the
chat that [ __ ] you talk about alpha
cuck you talk about a [ __ ] alpha cuck
that guy enters the [ __ ] chat that
guy enters the [ __ ] chat they do this
little thing on youtube where they have
a conversation about it now all the
stoolies and the joe rogan [ __ ]
trolls
are sending death threats of course and
like it's not just like you know a
[ __ ] comment or a dm i mean they're
doing that but these [ __ ] are
calling their families now last night
they posted a video with the audio of
someone calling and giving them a death
threat
these [ __ ] bone ends these [ __ ]
fragile white males they really are
entitled [ __ ] really are
entitled [ __ ] that they think
they can do this type of [ __ ] so i'm
sure portnoy will end up on our [ __ ]
are on it probably end up as the alpha
cut course you never know you never
[ __ ] know we'll have plenty of alpha
cucks come along
in the next two [ __ ] days
for sure
no way there won't be alpha cucks so i
think i'm gonna vote for brian here
uh of course kevin mccarthy's already
winning it looks like um kevin
mccarthy's gonna run away with it
i wonder if he'll run away with this as
fast as he ran away from that reporter
oh that [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
so kevin mccarthy's at 50 so go to the
tony michael's pod
uh vote for the the bone hint of the
week i'm gonna retweet this so it's at
the top of my timeline now
please go vote for bonehead of the week
we'll see you on friday about that one
by the way
we'll see you on friday okay let's go to
the timeline here let's make this bigger
so you folks can see
all right
of course there's the bone end of the
week poll that we just retweeted um this
is
speaking of brian kaelin you're still
here on chip
you're still here aren't you
so we'll get to this thread but brian
suave here he post this picture of what
appears to be his his pregnant lovely
lady at 28 weeks and you'll realize why
this is important here a minute and
caleb says is this you and he [ __ ]
around and found out didn't he uh
caitlyn says she's still she's still
here
oh you [ __ ] around and found out
kaylin's style this is the [ __ ] tweet
that this bonehead did
actually let's go back let's give kalyn
credit
yeah thanks for your tweet
i don't want to forget that okay let's
go
this is the this is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that this weirdo says
this is really [ __ ] weird just to
tweet this out by the way
by the way this is really [ __ ] weird
these [ __ ] weirdos are obsessed with
other people's body parts why why are
they so [ __ ] obsessed
it really does give little dick energy a
lot like this [ __ ] alpha cuck here
look at this [ __ ] guy look at this
[ __ ] guy
alpha cuck all the way
100 percent
give me a [ __ ] break this [ __ ] guy
all right let's go back
dear ladies can't you hear him saying
dear ladies
so jealous that you have beautiful
bodies and you would post pictures of
them
there is no reason whatsoever for you to
post pictures of yourself in low-cut
shirts
bikinis gross
brawl and underwear even grosser
and anything similar
ever
ever
ever like ever you shouldn't post that a
lady shouldn't post it
not to show your weight loss journey
not to show your newborn baby
not to document your bear story
your brothers okay so first off
brian
stop
stop talking about ladies okay
don't don't talk to the ladies it's not
a [ __ ] really it's not a good idea
hey look look who we got here look what
we got here look who decided to show up
we're talking about an alpha cuck here
and uh you know of course the the guy
the guy can't handle his microphone
typical game say say hi to everyone
say hi to gabe everyone even though he
can't say hi back i can say hi back i
can talk i hear you're talking about
these schmucks oh yes yes yes brian
schwa is it schwab or is it suave
i think it's
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah but he puts an
accent on the ears yeah
whether that was a
fabricated you know or like
created by him or not i don't know
hey
what's everyone saying hi gabe
hi gabe hello gabe what's up hey what's
up welcome gabe to the to the the tony
michaels podcast uh but yeah he's the
executive producer and co-host of the
show i'm trying to give you like an
intro i don't know maybe we should have
like a gabe intro like music or some
[ __ ]
yeah i don't know what that would be you
could run in like kevin mccarthy ran
away from a reporter
maybe i'll let the audience uh maybe the
you know what how about you guys throw
out some suggestions as to what my intro
music if i have any should be there you
go like like a like a wrestling bam
right right you know like you enter them
yeah like and every day i'll i'll
actually light live fireworks off in my
bedroom and right now
hopefully my landlord isn't watching
this well you know
you know
so um so so what do you think about this
guys this guy's tweet is spot on you
know he's talking to dear ladies and
then at the
end what is the your brothers what does
that mean is it like man i think it's
it's see here's the thing like he's this
he's this pastor right or of this uh
whatever that christian
oh i'm sure it's a fantastic church
right right
i think what he means is like you're
brothers because as a pastor he's like
oh we're all brothers and sisters so
he's saying as you know as your
respected brothers
please respect your body
and
uh do not do this don't show the newborn
baby don't show the weight loss don't
show the birth story also didn't you
just show a photo of him saying like
whatever how many weeks his wife was
pregnant yeah so uh well caitlin is it
is it difficult found this let's let's
go back to it right right is it
different is it different because
he said he shared it he shared it she
didn't share it right is that the is
that the day that is the difference yeah
it's well yeah absolutely men have the
right to be on social media sharing
whatever photo naked photos of women
that they want or pregnant photos or
their weight loss story men can do that
women can't right yeah that you know
there is a distinction i really yeah i
really love the double standard that
we've got this guy who is a
you know practicing follower of christ
has to put up these uh restrictions as
to what a woman can and can't do it's
like it's uh what it's their body it's
their [ __ ] choice okay right
don't come in and get all [ __ ] butt
hurt because you got a little aroused or
a little jealous right or envious that's
what this is
they don't want boners they're scared of
boners it makes them feel like you know
like oh i get all this this feeling
right when i get a boner they're so
[ __ ] scared of sex because here's the
thing because like you know i grew up in
the catholic church and you know study
christians
right yeah and so like
there was a point where like i got one
side of the church and then i got a
different side of the church
and i'll tell you this
it's all [ __ ] it's all terrible because
you mean the catholic church are just
christianity in general just like you've
got catholicism you know the
righteousness the pompous attitude the
entitlement i remember privilege yeah
yeah and then there's christianity which
in some ways i almost find even worse
because it's like a new age uh uh like
privilege and
and pompous attitude that people have
like i you know i was a part of a
christian youth group in high school
and to a degree it was fun and it was
great but at the same time there are
also moments when people be like oh i'm
better than this other person because
i'm you know i'm a follower of christ
even though i would see those people say
vile vulgar [ __ ] uh you know no
different than what joe rogan would say
and we would be like hey that's not cool
i'm like no that's cool school i go to
church and god forgives me it's like
that's not how that works that's that's
you can't just like wash away the sins
by saying oh it's all good god will get
me on sunday like
he doesn't that's not how it works
i wonder i wonder if the twitter gods
are going to forgive him for this tweet
here that he's posting of a pregnant
woman right
i mean 2013 crazy you know nine years
nine years ago you know almost a nine
nine year anniversary crazy he
definitely did not remember that he
posted a picture of his pregnant lady
when i but when i see stuff where
someone's like oh you're brothers like
okay first off don't speak on behalf of
the rest of us right exactly like you
are not
as uh
as great as you may seem right or or
like you might be able to stand by the
pulpit and the lectern and speak out to
the rest of the people in your church
and give them the the stories and and
try to connect uh different symbolism
and all this to different parts of the
story that you made up and how it
relates to this and that here's a shut
the [ __ ] up okay just shut the [ __ ] up
life would be a lot easier if religion
was not a problem or not not a thing
because obviously that's the forefront
of a lot of issues in in our in our
history throughout the world's history
and when we've got people that are
trying to
position themselves their uh
priorities their ideologies whatever
politics on to someone else to say
you shouldn't do this because x y z well
what happened to the actual the the the
aspect of free will right freedom
freedom
i can't yeah it's like i can't do this
on my own
my own free will my own freedom i i
can't choose myself
on my own my own body
my mind my spirit like these are all
things that they preach and they and
they practice
but then they'll
they'll push on to other people and say
you're not good enough because you
didn't accept christ you're not good
enough because you did not
do not just dissolve yourself of all
your ego and your your righteousness and
say i
am just a a child of god and a follower
of christ and shut the [ __ ] up okay if
you are going to be hypocritical you're
double standard [ __ ] and you're
going to say in your home versus on the
street versus in the church if it's not
consistent
then shut the [ __ ] up but also
stop telling people what to [ __ ] do
right you know and they that's the [ __ ]
that they do they claim that we're
trying to force them to do all these
things and
liberals are the fascist and they're
trying to force you to do like shut the
that's not even close to what is
happening right and you can see it in
the ratio here right like look at the
[ __ ] quote tweets this guy got like
almost 18 000 glow tweets now i'm not
gonna go down because there's nudity in
these in these things oh yeah so so
youtube would [ __ ] would kick this
video um which i want this video to live
on for a long time for this [ __ ]
idiot yeah but but the crazy that so
what here's what i did last night i'm
like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm gonna go
through and i'm gonna i liked as many
pictures as women were posting as i
possibly could like i went down and
hearted all of them boom boom boom i
didn't give a [ __ ] what it was showing
who what what the reason i just
liked all of them as many as i could but
there's like there's a lot of them
there's thousands of them and what i
would recommend
what i would recommend is don't go to
this post and don't go like all those
pictures and make sure
oh brian here knows that his brothers
aren't who he who aren't who they he
thinks they are we're not your [ __ ]
your i'm not your [ __ ] brother [ __ ]
i'm not yours brian brian
salve
is the type of guy
that would [ __ ] jerk it alongside
josh hawley right tight grip pornhub
kind of guy
that's who they are right again they are
the type of person that
temptation is is the worst thing and
they were afraid of it and they won't
accept it because temptation can be good
depending on how you you know go about
it but
this guy as well as many others within
the christian faith in that cult
look at it and they say well if i can't
enjoy it neither can you
and that's what it is in a day they're
jealous and they're envious that other
people actually are able to
express themselves and explore their
sexuality and their bodies and their
minds and their own actual freedom and
not feel like they're shackled to this
christianity
hypocritical mindset that you've got to
be one thing or the other and you can't
be bold and there's no gray area it's
either black or white right or wrong
left or right that's what it is
right and that's what these people are
talk right alpha cup exactly i i mean i
don't i don't think our intention or
your intention when you said that out
loud was to like like oh my god that
works so [ __ ] great but it just it
just
it just came out i was like that guy's
an alpha cuckoo like that's that was not
planned
exactly but that's exactly what is
happening here speaking alpha cux i know
you want to talk about this because i
know that you um you have received your
fair amount of trolls
and even even um in the last few days
people were saying racist [ __ ] about you
in comments right yeah
and we've seen we've seen this joe rogan
[ __ ] where and i think it was because
you called out joe rogan wasn't it yeah
i mean yeah well it was a
yeah yeah yeah it was i mean you called
him out you you called him out and they
were
right
because he was saying
right i called him out and i called
republicans and i said the republic
can party kkk you know party
uh are more upset
with joe rogan being called out for
being racist then joe rogan actually
being racist
meanwhile i go i like posted i go to
[ __ ] trader joe's with my girlfriend
we're going to get you know groceries
for the week meanwhile my messages are
blowing up and i've got people that are
like saying oh i'm wrong and joe rogan
works with black people and he's got
black friends so he can't be racist yeah
the black friendship like gang did
exactly and then they're they're pushing
down and uh they're like oh why don't
you call out these people that people
and i'm like i'm glad they're getting
called out right left right wherever
they are on the political spectrum
if they say the n word or say racist
stuff they should be called out yeah
call them out and see what their
response is right they're responses like
joe rogan so they [ __ ] you right and i
you know and to these people i even
commented to a couple and i said hey i'm
this is great i'm glad they're getting
called out they should be held
accountable i'm glad we both agree that
it should be fair on both sides and
they're like oh well that's not exactly
what's happening uh and i was like
okay somebody made videos i support
these videos if they're calling out as
an example of what people said that was
racist they said the n word or they said
something that was vulgar or that was
derogatory or whatever was we should be
held to the same standard right now
whether the full public
follows that is whatever but if
individual by individual i support that
if someone said that they should be
called out for it so people got really
upset and then of course people came in
calling me
uh
corny my corny ass but with that they
were saying like oh i hope you get
deported i hope you do this oh oh you
know obviously because because of your
last name right because i happen to be
mexican all of a sudden the assumption
is that i'm here illegally right mm-hmm
and that's your last name is sanchez
right oh oh boy oh boy look at this guy
you know it doesn't even matter if i was
born in this country not wish i was by
the way but you know that's regardless
well i mean you know you know it's you
know what's funny about the that type of
racism it's like all the people in the
southwest part of the country like ah
like that used to be mexico like we
stole it from them like how don't you
know that that mexican descendants of
mexicans are he were here before you
were right wrong before you were also
making the argument that we stole it
from mexico that's also doesn't make you
sound great like right
you keep tell you keep trying to brag
about how you stole land right
indigenous people right exactly you know
like my my ancestors as well like it it
doesn't make you conquered you right
it doesn't make you sound as cool as you
think it does
especially when you're talking about
like raping and pillaging and destroying
it like
you know mexico city was an advanced
civilization and then the spaniards came
in and basically [ __ ] on it and right
burned it down and tore it down and you
know anyway the the point is i've got
these people who are coming in and
saying joe rogan isn't racist but then
saying racist [ __ ] to me as a way to
defend joe rogan right like he's not
racist so i'm going to say racist [ __ ]
and defensively
so it's like i i i i'm not trying to i
like i don't understand what your logic
is are you you're trying to cover up
one racist remark with another racist
remark like
what what the [ __ ] is wrong with you and
we've seen this we've seen this reach a
high temperature because right um with
the joe rogan stuff patriot takes uh put
out a video uh which was an alex jones
video that alex jones made when he was
in a feud with joe rogan they were
pissed off at each other so uh alex
jones decided to get even with joe rogan
and post a video on the internet where
he's saying the n word over and over and
over again and then another video about
uh uh that's a time that joe rogan
describes how he went to watch planet of
the apes and he described the when he
got out of the car there were black
people there and he felt like he was in
africa and he was on the planet of the
apes
you know just racist [ __ ] tropes
they think it's funny they you know they
were i'm a comedian you know they hide
behind this than veil but the the issue
is is that
um on the internet that they they
actually drew in the mizella's brothers
which the mizella's brothers anyone not
that doesn't know out there and they
don't hide it they're jewish right
they're they're jewish and they they
they started and run midas touch
midastouch.com the mind is touch network
um in full disclosure we worked with
mind just last week on distributing an
interview and and to be to be frank with
you i i talk to the mizella's brothers
uh almost every week
but they're good guys they're good guys
they're doing good pro-democracy work in
this country whether you like it or not
which really if you don't like their
pro-democracy work that says something
more about you than it probably does
about them
but here's the thing is that
uh
it's a discount local and i don't know
and i don't know who the vocal is and it
doesn't [ __ ] matter who vocal is it
doesn't [ __ ] matter it's some [ __ ]
twitter account some [ __ ] anti-semite
probably who is going around accusing
people of being in a cabal which has
that [ __ ] trope of anti-semitism to
it right
so
what happens is dave portnoy i don't
know if you guys know that [ __ ] alpha
cuck but that [ __ ] decides to
retweet and blast this stuff and to put
it on and to give it to feed it to his
audience which his audience is full of a
bunch of alpha cucks let's just be frank
white fragile males who can't handle the
[ __ ] truth that they're pieces of
[ __ ] and their ideas are [ __ ] they just
can't handle it oh we like sports and we
want to beat our chest and we think it's
cool shut the [ __ ] up you are not tough
at all right so what happens is is dave
portnoy uh puts this on blast and what
the mizellas do brothers do is the the
strong thing for a man to do say hey
that's cool you want to have a
conversation let's have a conversation
man-to-man let's do this let's talk to
each other
they go on um to youtube and of course
we played it i think yesterday or the
day before
but they go on youtube they talked it
out sort of
dave portnoy
actually accused one of them
um of of saying the n-word right he said
he had proof and i didn't provide the
proof because he probably doesn't
[ __ ] have proof and even and then he
doesn't prove he can't verify the [ __ ]
exactly and not only that but even they
even brought it up and talked about it
in
the podcast
uh this week
and they discussed this whole thing and
how in the bar school whatever the [ __ ]
this thing is no no i'm saying might
have touched you oh okay yeah yeah they
discussed it this week to explain what
happened they're like right
right
because the the accusation is because
midas touch retweeted something they're
the ones behind all the rogue and [ __ ]
right and of course this vocal account
you know
these white
these fragile white males get in these
threads and they get boners about uh
jewish people being behind this big
thing to take down white people right
it's it's got white supremacy all over
it yep and local i wouldn't be surprised
if they got a nazi flag hanging in their
[ __ ] bedroom right would not surprise
me one [ __ ] bit this whole targeted
attack that they've had against myself
brothers like you know
is exactly that's the funny part is it's
a target attack against them is what
they're right and what they're accusing
them of doing to joe rogan right right
[ __ ] joe rogan he's a [ __ ] racist
live with it live with joe rogan just
because they ex just because they
retweeted a [ __ ] video that exposes
that your favorite [ __ ] podcaster is
a [ __ ] racist
you gotta live with that [ __ ]
you
no but you can't live with that that
makes sense that makes them upset the
fact that they're they're uh comedian
leader they're they're they're woke
brash blunt tells it how it is kind of
guy you know every [ __ ] joe rogan
he's a [ __ ] dip said racist stuff oh
no dude that's not cool that's an attack
against them because they take it
personally that's right they take it as
an attack against their leader and that
their their dude is an attack against
him which is similar to the trumpism
mindset which is like you attack him you
attack me right that's that's because
that's because they don't they don't see
joe rogan when he's doing his show as a
comedian and that [ __ ] hiding behind
comedy and [ __ ]
is just [ __ ] uh absolute [ __ ]
because they're his audience and port
noise audience because portnoy did the
same [ __ ] stupid thing on the goddamn
conversation that he had with the
mizella's brother i do comedy it's
supposed to be funny
well that's fine that's fine and all but
it's not comedy your audience doesn't
see this comedy and the reason why they
don't see it as comedy they see it
seriously is because they're calling
making phone calls to the mizellas
brothers and threatening to kill them
which is a [ __ ] crime you can't you
can't do that that's not a thing you can
do these people who think that it's
crazy because the other part of it is
like also portnoy is jewish so it's a
lot of his followers
are doing these they're like well i like
him he's jewish though these things
aren't anti-semitic
it's the same thing of like well i can't
be racist because i've got a black
friend it's porton always saying oh well
this wasn't racist when we had this
podcast because they're black employees
of mine i i it's like the insanity uh
the the [ __ ]
twisted messed up mindset that people
have where it's like well i have an
affiliation or association with this one
group so i can't actually be this thing
that's against them i can't be uh racist
or derogatory or whatever or just a joke
like how is that thing
set like how is that racist how how is
how is that unfair to them how is that
derogatory right it's a compliment it's
like
you know joe rogan going on the podcast
and saying like well how is it racist if
i say that uh that asian people are
smart at math like how is it racist if i
say uh so many jewish people are nobel
laureates or geniuses
like you're
i don't ah [ __ ] man well and you know
you know what gets me is because the my
zealous brothers actually defended joe
rogan for him being racist on this
podcast they actually created a speech
he could say
two days before we want to compete with
these ideas because we think our ideas
will our our our pro-democracy message
will beat the racist dividing message
right like that's what they said let him
[ __ ] continue on spotify and i i kind
of feel the same [ __ ] way if joe
rogan wants to speak into a microphone
fine if spotify doesn't find it
profitable then they'll take him down
which i think is gonna happen and the
reason why is because we had such big
names that have way bigger microphones
than joe rogan enter the chat like
dwayne the rock johnson right i think
that's he's got a way bigger microphone
speaking against rogan has such more of
an impact than than a music artist like
neil young taking down their music right
which brings me to this this kind of
this tweet here uh minus touch posted
this this morning last night after
receiving hundreds of hateful and
anti-semitic emails and dms following
the right-wing smear
campaign
members of midas touch were the target
of death threats the perpetrator made
dozens of phone calls to us our families
and our significant others um actually
you know let's go [ __ ] listen to this
thing i actually posted
i posted a clip from last night's
conversation though right they said
they'll play more of it i think tomorrow
on the podcast but uh
i listened to it last night um
well and here's here's the thing and
brett is the one who posted it and dear
dan it says i've got your name your
number and your home address i'll be
calling you so yeah this is the origin
this is the first one and then there's
the follow-up one where he actually had
a conversation he recorded it too oh
really okay so where's the follow up one
this one here uh no no this is the this
is the
warning one that they had well let's
play this one let's play this one here
let's play this one from brit cause i
think the one it's in that thread that
he has it too okay
let's play this one watch out for
yourself [ __ ]
watch out for yourself [ __ ]
so it's very simple he's just pulling
out phrases let's see you said is this
it here there you go boom
okay uh let's see
you with your daddy
you think you're a tough guy dan
no is there something you want to say
is there something you want to man up to
right now man to ma'am
you know what's funny about this
dan thinks he's so [ __ ] tough that
he's gonna pick on a mizella's brother
because he's some kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
or some [ __ ] like that he thinks i'll
just call and leave a message i'll [ __ ]
with this guy i'll make him i'll make
him go
it's not just because he left voicemails
and messages for other family members
and other friends
yeah but brett picked up the [ __ ]
phone let's listen no no i think brett
called him yep oh bro he called his dad
from what i understand oh okay i got you
are you so do you apologize
i do
are you gonna call everybody who you
called and send text messages and
profusely apologize for what you've done
this is your chance i'm not i'm not mad
at you i'm just talking to you man to
man you don't call somebody you don't
call somebody's wife you don't threaten
them and harass them
i didn't threaten anyone you told me to
hang myself
you said you were coming for me so
i didn't i did not i haven't recorded
actually
and so you could either apologize man to
man say you're sorry to me apologize to
everybody you called take it back
i'm gonna have to take the necessary
action call the authorities right after
this phone call
of course i will all right i'm just i'm
not positive who
you know who i called all right well you
call everybody back who you called you
know you missed calls
man up about this be a man
[ __ ] alpha cuck little [ __ ]
you got caballed [ __ ] danno you
little [ __ ] here's the thing here's the
thing these [ __ ] idiots out there
think that that liberals aren't [ __ ]
tough and liberals won't come after you
liberals won't stand up for themselves
you're [ __ ] wrong you're dead [ __ ]
wrong there's right and there's wrong
and this is [ __ ] wrong to call
someone's [ __ ] family because of
something they said now i don't get this
me and you have talked about this i
don't get this kind of [ __ ] i don't get
this racist [ __ ] [ __ ] turned around
on me because i'm a white dude with a
goddamn beard
i don't get that [ __ ] and there's a
reason for it there's a reason for it
and it's because they're [ __ ] racist
not not just rogan and portnoy himself
and the it's the [ __ ] people that
they hire it's the messages that they
send and it's the [ __ ] trumpets that
they send out to these [ __ ] alpha
cuts and their goddamn stoolie army and
they're [ __ ] roganites right
[ __ ]
that's what we're talking about when
you're saying this [ __ ] about
misinformation and disinformation and
spreading it around
these people think it's okay no this is
not [ __ ] okay they think it's okay
that they can call someone they can
threaten them they can harass their
family this is the type of [ __ ] that
we had the last four years that trump
was like yeah you kicked their ass yeah
we're gonna do the son of a [ __ ]
that's the type of thing we let the
[ __ ] boogeyman out of the closet and
now he won't go back in and now everyone
thinks that it is okay in society to do
this type of [ __ ] not like they weren't
doing it before but now people are gonna
do it and then on the phone call well i
didn't say that i didn't do it oh we
have a recorded call well i don't
remember exactly who i called or what i
said shut the [ __ ] up you just made a
death threat you threatened to have
someone kill themselves and then now
you're [ __ ] scared like a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] because you got called out
because brett called your dad and made
you [ __ ] apologize on the phone
that's right let's listen to the rest of
this
i will all right this could be a
learning moment for you all right you
don't call strangers and do that [ __ ]
all right so i i i think i called this
number and
spammed it and i apologize
spammed it
spammed it what the [ __ ] you he called
him multiple times he still he still
can't even man up and say what the [ __ ]
he did
what a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what a bunch of [ __ ] little [ __ ]
punk ass [ __ ] the snowflakes baby
they are
melting away [ __ ] alpha cups oh
you're the one who threatened me before
i didn't mean that because i started
when i didn't need to
i'm just curious like honestly like why
did you think that was okay
i didn't think it was okay so why did
you i mean you called me it wasn't like
you called me once accidentally called
me like i'm not trying to give you a
hard time i'm just trying to like have
an honest conversation like man-to-man
like you thought it was okay to call me
nine times you thought it was okay to
call my wife you thought it was okay to
call my brother like like what i just
honestly like man-to-man like what what
is it like like just tell me i'll talk
to you about it
it was it was not it was not okay
and um
it was
inappropriate you
and that's i mean that's fair i mean
that the thing is is that he knows
there's going to be consequences right
he knows there's going to be [ __ ]
consequences you think you can just call
up and threaten somebody's life in your
[ __ ] parents basement and then once
your parents get the [ __ ] call on
their [ __ ] landline phone or their
cell phone and they say hey can i talk
to uh can i talk to daniel is this
daniel's dad and they're like yeah yeah
why oh well your son [ __ ] threatened
my life what are you talking about oh
here's a recording oh holy [ __ ] all
right let's get him
brings him out and calls him on and
talks him on the phone meanwhile i love
the fact that brett's like man to man
let's talk man to man right i want to
say this man to man because at the end
of the day they're he's not a man he's a
cuck he's a boy he's you know insecure
you know
ass [ __ ] you know
born and bred in a world that said it
was okay to do this but when it comes to
uh you know
actually real world
yeah confronted with the consequences of
your actions thinking that oh you know
what the internet's anonymous oh i'm
gonna call this person and i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna do this anonymously oh
well you [ __ ] idiot you left your
voice you left you let your [ __ ] you
didn't even make it anonymous you just
called and and made it a missed call and
then you called multiple times and then
you use that same number to call other
people and [ __ ] threaten them and
harass them and you think there's not
going to be consequences you think this
is what playing call of duty you could
just say [ __ ] online and not have to
worry about any sort of any sort of
issue or or consequence of the actions
that you made no buddy no no no no no
you're [ __ ] you are [ __ ] and now
you're becoming infamous
right well let me tell you something
that i i don't care what the political
affiliation is um no one should have
their family members called threatened i
don't give a [ __ ] who they are you
should not have your family members
called you personal calls and threaten
your [ __ ] life and and try to make
you scare you into changing what you're
doing with your political opinion we
have political opinions in this country
we have the [ __ ] right to them and
you don't get to threaten someone with
their life or their family's life
to try to to try to silence them i don't
care who the [ __ ] they are i don't care
if it's the my zealous brothers i don't
care if it's portnoy himself i don't
give a [ __ ]
you don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] this is a
free [ __ ] country you are welcome to
your [ __ ] your your goddamn political
affiliations and your political thoughts
you can be a [ __ ] racist you can be a
[ __ ] racist dano
you can love the racism that is spewed
on rogan's show and your little stooly
shows
and your [ __ ] macho machismo [ __ ]
which dano it's not macho machismo it's
not it's not manly it's a you're a bunch
of punk ass [ __ ] listen to a a bunch
of punk-ass [ __ ] like rogan and and
and [ __ ] portnoy those [ __ ]
wouldn't stand up for a goddamn woman
wouldn't stand up for someone trying to
be who they want to be because they're a
bunch of goddamn punk-ass [ __ ]
and it really pisses me off and i don't
care who it is what it is
i don't care if if what your political
affiliation is what your sexuality is
what the [ __ ] color your skin is i
don't give a [ __ ]
you don't do that type of [ __ ] this is a
free goddamn country you're welcome to
your [ __ ] ideas you're welcome to
your political opinions and and we can
have this out in the in the [ __ ]
arena of free speech you don't [ __ ]
threaten someone's family you don't call
and threaten someone with their [ __ ]
lives you don't do that [ __ ] yeah and to
use
and to use a a political affiliation as
an excuse right or your anti-semitism
and your in your bigotry and your racism
is [ __ ] disgusting right you little
dick energy alpha cuck looking head ass
right yep that's it that's it yeah i i
mean i i don't even know how else more
to explain this and and again i'm i i
know the myzlas brothers i i like that
we've had them on our show that's how we
entered the [ __ ] chat exactly because
i thought it was a [ __ ] gotcha we
were playing [ __ ] sports trivia and
they're like look at these guys they're
behind it all you're talking about
stopping the steel and all this [ __ ]
they they went on this podcast and
revealed themselves behind the [ __ ]
curtain what the [ __ ] are you talking
about shut the [ __ ] up i don't
understand you're ignorant you're
bigoted you're racist you're sexist
misogynistic
shut the [ __ ] up okay the other the
other thing too about this story that is
just [ __ ] laughable is how how they
switched from
somehow midas touch had this coordinated
attack against joe rogan to the entire
attack now is towards my like towards my
touch like the whole attack like
they retweeted a few things these people
are calling these [ __ ] giving
them death threats
death threats i i seriously doubt
because i know a lot of the midas money
i really seriously doubt that the midas
mighty went and said anything the
portnoy or any of the stoolies that was
to the level of threatening them or
their families lives yeah they they will
go and i know the minus mighty they'll
go into a political arena and have it
out with you now rather it be in a chat
or elsewhere they will definitely they
will definitely try to beat your ass at
the ballot box and they should be
they should be you don't [ __ ] you don't
[ __ ] with people who are who are
passionate politically especially dano
if you don't know a [ __ ] thing about
politics all you want to do is listen to
your little little white racist down in
austin texas called joe rogan just
listen to him listen to him have your
deep-seated racism live with it you know
no one's stopping you stop
don't [ __ ] backpedal once you get
called out once you literally get a call
from the person that you threatened
their life
and then say oh uh
i did i don't know who i i'm just shut
the [ __ ] up you made an action and
there's a consequence for it okay you
can't take you can't backpedal and try
to excuse yourself and make something up
as to why it's okay or why that was just
a joke or why you were just messing
around no no no once you start going
against people and threatening their
lives it becomes serious [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's right well and when it gets
serious that's when they get snowflakey
and they run away and they cry on the
phone for their daddy
logical says here on twitch uh midas
leads the way s sucks this happened to
its members only gives them more fuel to
continue to forward their message and i
think that's that's the other thing that
they they're the big miscalculation yeah
from portnoy rogan and their [ __ ]
followers is that somehow this is gonna
make them go away you people are [ __ ]
dumb
right we are we again we have been
affiliated with minus touch in this last
week because we actually they partnered
with us on the distribution of the tasha
adams and dakota adams uh interview they
helped us with that so we've been
officially
affiliated with them but they don't tell
me what to say
they don't [ __ ] i've never i've never
got a conversation with one of them
saying what'd you say how'd you say it
they didn't even question what the [ __ ]
it was that was in the goddamn interview
when we went and sold it to him they
knew they knew it was a pro-democracy
message because they know that's what we
do and that's what our [ __ ] aim is
and you [ __ ] out there
just wanting to promote racism and have
have your racism have it you can have it
just go crawl back underneath your
[ __ ] rock yeah and the one thing the
last thing i'll say on this is at the
end of the day portnoy tries to to go
after the myself brothers in midas touch
and so does his vocal account and other
people right and along the way it begins
building up and building up and building
up into an anti-semitic uh type of
rhetoric right which is insane right
because it started from these guys are
doing an attack oh and then they had
they had messages they were like are you
guys jewish just wondering you guys are
three jewish brothers right which is
like i don't know how this is any way
associated with what's going on here but
that's the whole cabal thing right
exactly that's that [ __ ] language but
as it builds up you see that this
narrative of like they're attacking me
they're coming after me uh it's
anti-portnoy anti-joe rogan here's the
thing that's going on though because
their message is now slowly devolving
into
this anti-semitic rhetoric and death
threats that they have lost all and any
credibility that they once had because
right now even to make the argument that
they're behind it right even if they
were to say like oh they're behind all
the stuff doesn't excuse anything that
you've said anything you've threatened
because now it's just like the let's go
brandon crew at first like it's a joke
it's an inside joke all dumb whatever
now it's affiliated with [ __ ] nazis
right they're the let's go brandon crt
nazis exactly and now local and dave
portnoy are attached to this group that
have made death threats against the
mizella's brothers because they're
jewish and they have in a a partnership
with patriot takes because patriotics
was getting [ __ ] death threats right
which is great which is crazy to me that
that dave portnoy would even march down
this road because he is jewish
i just i can't even [ __ ] i mean the
the
the [ __ ] that happens here is just
beyond beyond the pale it's [ __ ] vile
and and and again it's weak and
snowflakey that they have to make these
attacks on people because of their
political beliefs if you
because portnoy even says it in the
[ __ ] conversation that they had and i
welcome dave portnoy on this show dave
if you want to come on the show fine
[ __ ] you come on i'll [ __ ] have a
conversation with you you ain't gonna
[ __ ] like it you definitely i
definitely will not [ __ ] hold back
like the mizellas they were much much
kinder to you than i ever will [ __ ]
be
ever will [ __ ] be but let me tell you
something
during that conversation dave portnoy
even admitted that he's not political
and he doesn't have political beliefs
and he doesn't vote so what the [ __ ] are
you in the conversation for why are you
trying to enter the conversation well i
know why they're trying to enter the
conversation they want their army
against these [ __ ] because if you were
there during the youtube video live and
you can go watch it might as touch still
has the live chat up you can see who
they're affiliated with they're not
hiding that they're [ __ ] maga they're
not hiding that they're white
supremacist they're not hiding that they
love trump they're not they don't hide
it it's white supremacy through and
through and that's why the attack on the
mizella's brothers has happened and
that's why they want to pile on and
actually frankly
i i hate that i hate that their families
and them are getting death threats right
but at the same time i know i know
what's going to happen with the midas
mighty all right they're important and
here's the thing portnoy opened up that
[ __ ] door that's right he opened it
up and brought in jordy's uh fiance
that's right and made that okay and then
all of those [ __ ] stully alpha that
was the point though with that don't i
think exactly that's the type because
it's the same type of [ __ ] that trump
would do we're talking about a topic you
get agitated you don't have a good solid
footing what do you do you pivot and
make an accusation then what have you
done you've distracted the conversation
from actually actually the actual
[ __ ] point the focal point the whole
thing of why they're having this thing
right not like oh well that up but i
know this text messages which ends up
being not real but you know what now
he's throwing it out there right now so
it has to be real to them right exactly
then you've got people i've got to tell
brett until brett mizellis calls your
ass and [ __ ] and says hey
[ __ ] man to man tell me what you
say right and then uh
then it's all [ __ ] it's all well that
was online that wasn't in real life no
it's real life [ __ ] and then
pisses me off go ahead i was gonna say
to tell you how insane it is just by
association i did a video uh in
partnership with midas touch last week
and i have all these comments of people
that are in there that are saying
crazy racist [ __ ] against me but also
bringing into myself brothers and
talking about jordy and whoever else but
here's thing i just partnered with them
on a video it's just like oh you know
how you can attach two people or three
people on a instagram video well now
i've got all the [ __ ] stooly bros
coming in on that video and making [ __ ]
up about me or saying stuff you know
that i have to report or it's just dumb
idiotic but it's it's just by
association that they all of a sudden
have has said oh well here you go after
this guy now because he made a video of
them what the [ __ ] is that about that's
the type of [ __ ] that this group is
behind they're trying to troll because
they can do it behind some anonymous
account
well guess what you're gonna get you're
gonna get [ __ ] called out and it's
gonna happen and you're gonna [ __ ]
cry and [ __ ] and moan and say oh you
didn't mean it it was just a joke don't
be so sensitive when you're the one
who's being [ __ ] sensitive and crying
just like little dano did on the phone
that's right that's right well caitlin
makes a good point says that the the
minus money handled it with class as
always which they will they're gonna
listen if you think the midas mighty is
is not gonna fight this at the ballot
box because that's the point of the
whole [ __ ] super pac might as touch
the midas media network is pro-democracy
[ __ ] they're not talking about [ __ ]
who won the basketball game and why
someone's why why someone wears this or
where's that or or a pizza [ __ ] what
what does porno need is pizza reviews or
some stupid [ __ ] that's not what they're
doing they're doing democracy [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] it's politics that's what they do
that's what they do and just because you
don't like it [ __ ] you [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them [ __ ] [ __ ] them
i i and and i hate to have to come on
here again i mean this is the second or
third time that we've had to come on and
give our opinion about this and i'm not
defending them my zealous brothers or
minus mighty i don't have to they will
completely defend themselves but i know
this is a conversation we have to have
in the year 2022 [ __ ] ridiculous
[ __ ] insane it's ridiculous and
that this is okay against a population
of people that is on the world is point
two percent
right right
this is not okay and to excuse it as
like well these guys were attacking uh
joe
and these guys were attacking dave poor
knowing go [ __ ] cry and jerk off okay
right because that's what it is you guys
go watch the racist [ __ ] that you want
to watch go listen to the racist and be
go be racist
go be racist
go do that if you want to do that you
have freedom do that don't do it down on
it but make yourself public and known
but you do not have the right you do not
have the right to [ __ ] threaten
people you do not have the right to
[ __ ] harass people you don't have the
[ __ ] right you don't have it it's not
a thing you that you are supposed to do
are allowed to do and frankly when you
step over the line like dano did it
becomes a criminal matter so [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him
are you are you uh you're running out of
time here i i would say yeah i got it
all right
well uh stick around thanks for staying
with us say bye to gabe everybody we'll
see you maybe we'll see you tomorrow go
vote for the bone end of the week and
just a reminder just be a good [ __ ]
human yeah decent you know you don't
have to be like a good just like just be
ceased
right don't make death threats maybe
respond to yourself first and then
you'll respect others right maybe
that'll work stick around we'll be right
back
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the drip lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew feed the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging with us
through the break
what do you think about the gay
brand he's getting better at that and he
needed them on fire on fire this week
about this thing it just uh
it really is [ __ ] stupid that we have
to do this [ __ ] in this in this day and
age that we have to tell people that you
can't you can't you can't threaten
people's lives like that's not a thing
that you can do you really you really
shouldn't do that that's not that's not
a cool thing like i thought we learned
this a long time ago but maybe we didn't
maybe we didn't and you can't threaten
them or their [ __ ] families calling
their [ __ ] families
there is nothing there is nothing that
pisses a real man off a real man i'm
talking not danno not [ __ ] pornoid
not these [ __ ] stoolies not these
[ __ ] alpha cucks there is nothing
that pisses off a real man more
and make and makes them want to have a
conversation with someone than them
threatening their family trust me
i i doubt there's any real man out there
that wouldn't want to do that have a
conversation man to man with someone
over what they would [ __ ] say to
their family members
and i think that's the point if you
listen to the video of brett he's not
he's not threatening this guy he's not
coming after this guy he's just saying
hey you own up to it be a man own up to
it tell me what you said and apologize
apologize and i'll accept your apology
so i don't know how many more of these
phone calls they've gotten are gonna get
but it's probably gonna be a lot more
because these uh these fragile white
males they don't give up easily they're
entitled i i know these types i've seen
these types
like i just round these tights my whole
[ __ ] life
that's who they are i think that's why i
don't get the hate i don't get it i
don't i i was telling gabe this morning
uh in in the dm i was telling him that
uh because i was una i was i was i don't
respond to trolls you guys know i
[ __ ] give him crickets unless it's
like chris chris is probably here in the
chat chris are you here in the chat he's
not a troll anymore he's a hate watcher
and we like to have him here on the show
i would i would i would welcome any of
the stoolies any of the rogue knights to
come listen to this show
to see to see what macho machismo can do
right
i don't i don't hide that you know i
don't hide who i am or what i am
i don't i don't hide behind some kind of
[ __ ] false
false [ __ ] image i am who i am
i'm a white guy with a beard who's from
the midwest who sounds like a trumper i
[ __ ] i wear a goddamn red hat but i aim
i aim i aim my beliefs in the opposite
direction the way that they would say it
because i think that's what we should do
because i don't think you should hide
who you are
but that doesn't mean you don't you you
don't have to be decent just because you
think you're a man and you gotta pound
your chest
and you gotta hate women like [ __ ]
brian earlier brian suave or whatever
the [ __ ] his name is hating on [ __ ]
women
what is it any of your [ __ ] business
what what someone does with their
[ __ ] twitter account they want to
post pictures of their boobs and twitter
allows them to do that shut the [ __ ] up
go do what you want to do on your
goddamn account stop being so goddamn
snowflakey and [ __ ] be worried about
what someone else is doing on theirs get
the [ __ ] out of here with that
if a woman wants to post pictures of her
body on her twitter account
she can do it it's her [ __ ] right
it's her [ __ ] account as long as she
ain't breaking terms of services [ __ ] a
man can do it too i've seen i seen
george
han you guys know george george is one
of my favorites the for me rants he
posted a picture
he posted a picture it's one of the
quote tweets you gotta go back to that
thread and look at that thread
it's a fantastic thread it'll it'll take
you a couple hours
to go through it but you really should
go back to that thread of brian suave
because i'm sure brian i'm sure brian is
christian as he is
and as godly as he is he probably
listens not only to [ __ ] joe rogan
but probably portnoy as well he's
probably a stooly would be my guess
that's why he's posting [ __ ] tweets
about how women shouldn't do this or
women shouldn't do that and your
brother's pinning us all in on that on
his [ __ ] tweet get the [ __ ] out of
here
get the [ __ ] out of here some of us some
of us don't give a [ __ ] what who someone
loves some of us don't give a [ __ ] about
what gender you are some of us don't
give a [ __ ] about your st
you get to have whatever sexuality you
want we are not focused on other
people's genitalia you're [ __ ]
weirdos you matt walsh types
[ __ ] worried about what bathroom
someone's going in what kind of rather
they got a dick or vagina in their pants
they're all [ __ ] worried about other
people's [ __ ] sexuality their
genitalia who they love who they don't
love you people are [ __ ] weirdos
[ __ ] weirdos most people don't run
around worried about that [ __ ]
they go into the bathroom they do their
thing they get out they love who they're
going to love if they if they want to
[ __ ] they [ __ ] who they want to [ __ ]
consensually of course
if it's man woman woman man
a trans woman a trans man get over it
quit being such a goddamn snowflake you
are not being oppressed you fragile
white [ __ ] males just because the
myself brothers who were jewish retweet
patriot takes because he posted a video
that alex jones made to [ __ ] to
[ __ ] try to dig at joe rogan
months and months and years ago
it's some kind of [ __ ] cabal and you
bring you bring their their jewish
religion into it and then you call and
threaten their families you dumb
[ __ ]
and it's all part of the same ilk the
same [ __ ] the charlie kirks the ben
shapiro's the [ __ ] matt walshes the
dan bonginos yeah i call you out tucker
carlson you [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ] and now you
got portnoy in the mix that
[ __ ] and again i welcome any of
those names i just said they are welcome
here to come have a conversation with me
i doubt they will
highly [ __ ] doubt that they would
[ __ ] come on my show and try to
[ __ ] confront me about their views
doubt it
good [ __ ] luck
[ __ ] alpha cucks
all right let's get back to the [ __ ]
list round up here
there's some new stuff trending it looks
like um of course dolly parton's
trending i want to go to this uh dolly
parton um has announced the program to
cover the cost of tuition books fees uh
for any employees pursuing their higher
education and i think this is at
dollywood i don't know if it's at her
other properties you know she um dolly
parton is
not only is she a magnificent singer a
great woman and a beautiful person but
she also is rich as [ __ ] and she knows
she knows business
she knows it she's smart as [ __ ]
do not [ __ ] with dolly parton she's
beautiful she's smart she's funny and
she's [ __ ] rich and she knows
business uh she has a um
uh a uh uh like like a theater down in
branson we're talking about branson
missouri it's um it's called dolly
stampede it used to be called dixie
stampede is what she used to call it but
she took the dixie off when she when she
actually received some messages from her
friends to say that's offensive and she
took it down because she's a decent
human being and a good human at that
valley pardon is a good human
that we we need more dolly partons in
the world
um not just rich and beautiful but smart
and decent people is what we need uh rex
chapman tweets her dolly continues to
lead the way now yes she does
yes she does and let's let's give credit
to dolly
for being a good
beautiful human
that's what's all we're asking that's it
that's all we're asking that's all we're
asking be yourself dolly's herself if
you ever watch an interview dolly's
herself
mayo says i don't know mayo's still with
us here but in a world full of kevin
mccarthy's be a dolly barton yes please
and thank you
this is good news here
this is what the world should be this is
the [ __ ] list i should have to go
through i'll have to if we did more
dolly parton [ __ ]
in this world in this country if we get
to a position i'm gonna have to change
the name of the show from the [ __ ] list
it won't be the [ __ ] list anymore
and i i i'm i'm welcoming the day that
we have to change the part of the show
called the [ __ ] list that we have to
change it because it's no longer the
[ __ ] list i doubt it
we've got enough of these [ __ ] in this
world these alpha cuck types
they'll continue to make this list the
[ __ ]
with the news um i don't know what this
is
this don't say gay thing i did not go
into this thread earlier
um and i have no idea so i'm fresh to
this um
y'all hurry up says florida is trying to
pass a bill where parents can sue a
school for saying gay
but don't say gay bill i hope climate
change sinks florida's [ __ ] first
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
catfish yak
she she hopes that
that um
florida
goes first thank you for the the laugh
this morning i'm not sure what this bill
is
but it looks like um
ron desantis in the state of florida
um you know we have him mj says desantis
mj's in florida
mj knows this governor well uh all too
well probably um but um
george we talked about george earlier
ron desantis can go [ __ ] himself yes i i
believe he he should cannon and and will
i think florida's winnable i think he'll
be [ __ ] right off in that election
uh but it looks like they're trying to
write a bill that you can't say gay
i guess in the school i guess this is
because you know it hurts their [ __ ]
feelings right
the truth the truth always hurts their
[ __ ] feelings
that someone can't refer to themselves
as gay what is this what is this [ __ ]
that they're hiding behind they get gay
geek it's so [ __ ] sensitive you ever
noticed that they always accuse liberals
of being sensitive ah you [ __ ] you
can't have bad libtards and oh you're
get the [ __ ] out of here you snowflake
[ __ ] you punk ass [ __ ] you
can't even handle the word gay get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
amy lindsay's ron desantis
backs the don't say gay bill which bans
the discussion of
sexual orientation in schools this is
discrimination plain and simple
oh i see
i see what this is i see what it is of
course it's a fascist thing of course it
is it's us and the others type [ __ ] you
know that's what there are these
fascists do
they always do the us and the others
mayo says don't say gay [ __ ] you that's
what i say
i'd say say gay all you want
and if people of a certain sexual
orientation want to have discussion in a
public school about their sexual
orientation well [ __ ] you
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
this is more of the bathroom bill than
being scared of people
this this is more
white fragile males being terrified that
they don't know their sexuality right
that's what this is they're insecure
about their sexuality
and they've always had this thing that
that gay men can't be manly you are a
dumb [ __ ] you are you are a
stupid [ __ ] if you think a gay man can't
be manly you are [ __ ] dumb
[Laughter]
ah you you obviously you obviously are a
[ __ ] alpha cuck if you think a gay
man can't be manly
jesus [ __ ] christ these people
so it looks like
looks like these [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ]
don't want to have people talking about
you know
being gay i guess i guess is the thing
uh steve offsider said this don't say
gay bill and florida is appalling
now punishing teachers for acknowledging
gay people exist it's archaic
if you want to ban an actual offensive
word from florida schools
may i suggest desantis
oh steve
steve
steve
thank you steve
you know i like the jokey jokes i like
the comedy oh here's chris in chris is
here everyone say hi to chris everyone
say hi to chris we're glad you're here
chris we are we're glad you're here
um you you are you are one of the people
who come watch you don't say hateful
bigoted stuff you don't um
um so we appreciate it even though we
may disagree chris uh you're you're
you're good you're good with us you're
good with the [ __ ] army here uh
you're good with us so stay with us even
though even though we may disagree
on a lot of things um i'm glad you watch
i'm glad you listen and i hope you
invite your friends to come listen and
they're as decent as you are chris okay
let's see let's go back
let's go back to the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends let's see who else we
got here oh 100 of americans this was
not trending earlier i don't know what
this is
but 100 percent of americans i don't
know uh
oh thomas massey has entered the chat of
course
of course speaking of alpha cucks
oh my god it just doesn't end with these
[ __ ]
doesn't end and there's such an endless
list of these [ __ ] [ __ ] bags
just doesn't [ __ ] end
then i know that's what this is
i know that's what this is it's from
this tweet
oh my god
over 70 percent of americans who died
with covid
died on medicare
and some people want medicare for all
you are such a dumb [ __ ] you see
okay so here's the thing
here's what thomas massey's trying to do
other than be a [ __ ] idiot
okay
they have had no [ __ ] policies
they've been running on no policy no
[ __ ] position other than they want to
be fascist
guns
and trump is our god like that's it
that's it full stop that's all they've
got that's all they've had for a long
[ __ ] time almost six goddamn years
jesus christ they can't even they can't
even they can't even figure out that the
next election is closer than the last
one
like literally the [ __ ] election that
we're about to have is closer to us than
the last one they're still bitching
about still trying to overturn they're
still trying to [ __ ] undo our vote
they still haven't figured that [ __ ]
[ __ ] out
because they have no [ __ ] policy they
have no positions because their ideas
[ __ ] suck and they know that we know
that their [ __ ] ideas [ __ ] suck
they're [ __ ] horrible that's why they
can't say these [ __ ] this [ __ ] out loud
now here's one thing they they do know
with this medicare for all right they do
know that democrats in the last primary
for the presidential election rejected
medicare for all they rejected it
uh elizabeth warren ran on it bernie
sanders ran on it and biden ran
opposite of it we're not gonna do
medicare for all he said we're not doing
that thing
we're not doing that thing
we're not gonna do that thing right
that's what he said that's what he said
and biden won handily against bernie
sanders
and you know these republicans know they
know that medicare for all that medicare
for all is a wedge issue in democrats
you see that
you see what this motherfucker's trying
to do
they know what they're doing here
they're trying to drive wedges in
between democrats right they're trying
to get us to fight whether medicare for
all is good or not right that's what
they're trying to do [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we're not gonna have that argument we
shouldn't have that argument and if
you're out there tweeting about that
argument you're you bought in you bought
their [ __ ] bait hook line sinker you
bought it
so if you're pro democracy don't take
debate here on this [ __ ] stupid thing
we should drive wedges in between them
that's probably what the hundred percent
of americans um is about because 100 of
americans think tom massey is a [ __ ]
idiot
seventy percent of americans who died
from cover died on
died on medicare
you stupid [ __ ] we were saying that from
the beginning
that we had to protect
older folks and people who are
vulnerable in this country and most of
the older folks and people who are
vulnerable in this country are on
medicare you [ __ ] idiot
by default
dumb [ __ ]
and some people want medicare for all no
most people don't want medicare for all
you know what most people want they
don't want to go [ __ ] broke over a
medical bill
that's how we drive the wedge you see
the messaging there we don't want
medicare for all we just don't want to
go broke over a medical bill
that's it i think most american families
just don't want to have to file
bankruptcy because they got in an
accident
because they can they they got cancer
because they developed a disease over
time because they had a child that was
born with a disease
they don't want to [ __ ] lose their
way of life and their well-being over an
illness
that is beyond their control
i think that's what most americans want
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're voting for
bernie sanders joe biden or donald trump
most americans would agree that they
want that
thomas massey's a [ __ ] idiot and your
tweet sucks [ __ ]
it sucks
it's a horrible [ __ ] tweet delete it
yes i want to [ __ ] tweet that thing
oh let's see what else we got here
oh [ __ ]
helen kennedy oh my god this is
fantastic helen kennedy says many people
who died do so in hospitals ban
hospitals right
100 percent of americans are having a
good laugh at your expense thomas that's
a hundred percent right the peop they're
[ __ ] boneheads
just complete [ __ ] boneheads they
don't get it
they won't get it they're not gonna get
it they're not going to
let's see if we can find
um bill lights says 100 of americans who
died coveted wouldn't have to read this
[ __ ]
i just did and again
if you're not aware what they're trying
to do here what they're trying to do is
they're trying to drive a wedge about
medicare for all they're trying to bait
the the national
the national discussion back into
politics right
they're trying to bait it back in
they're trying to get us to go after
each other on medicare for all they're
trying to get us to argue
not just out here on twitter and in real
life they're trying to get democrats in
congress to argue about this they're
trying to get the media to argue about
this which the media will buy this the
media be be aware be aware if you're out
there turn your cable off for a couple
[ __ ] days
because the media is gonna buy this
stupid [ __ ] hook line sinker they're not
going to say what i'm the [ __ ] to say
that this is [ __ ] stupid and it's
bait it's [ __ ] bait and i have the
discussion about medicare for all i
don't give a [ __ ] we already done did
this we had this decession in the
democratic primary the americans decided
this already
they decided it already we did this
decision we did this thing
where we had a primary we'll have
another one in 2024 and possibly 2028
for a democrat
we'll do it again we'll have this
discussion again in a few years but we
already had this discussion we do not
need to have this discussion inside of
our party
or inside the country for that matter
what we the discussion we do need to
have is to make sure people don't go
[ __ ] broke
over a goddamn medical bill
[ __ ] thomas massey
well
it's a damn shame we already got the
bonehead of the week up because that
[ __ ] would be on there again
uh speaking of bonehead of the week go
vote
go vote for the bone end of the week
follow us at tonymichaelspod
on twitter and at tonymichaels and i am
gabe sanchez
there on the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
that way you can vote for bone end of
the week here's our contestants this
week
brian suave or whatever the [ __ ] this
guy is
um forrest gump i mean um representative
kevin mccarthy and then jared kushner
those are our
those are our contestants speaking of mr
mccarthy let's go do that
where are you i'm gonna have to search
it i guess
i'm gonna have to search the thread
i guess we're gonna have to search the
thread
kevin
oh yeah he's all over
all right here's the kevin mccarthy
thread
let's open her up
oh look who's at the top always at the
top mayo you are always right there
can we please have every reporter
bombard kevin mccarthy with questions
tomorrow
i'll love it
i love it yep let's do that let's get
this [ __ ] on the run like let's
see how fast he can run how much he can
run he's gonna have to put like his
[ __ ] tennis shoes on tennis shoes and
some sports shorts do this much running
um there are some good videos of this
this is the year um one of the originals
rachel scott as it posted here um it's
not very long because it doesn't have to
be because he he tries to get away from
this reporter really [ __ ] fast here
we go
you know what make it an appointment
okay it's not good it's not gonna be
good
oh it's not good to do interviews in
hallways uh because you're gonna ask me
questions that i don't wanna answer
uh rachel is the one who asked the
leader about the legitimate political
discourse and he told her it's not good
to do them and always
it's not good it's not good to do these
things and always always
are bad place to do these things get the
[ __ ] out of here but here's what i will
tell you here's um here's here's the
good news about this video is uh we got
a lot of people on the internet that
like the internet these things
here's
uh here's gabe's rumor has it kevin
mccarthy can run that 40 yard dash in
4.2 seconds
rumor has it
i don't know i'm
just saying
thank you and this is the the video from
rachel scott that that gabe posted here
let's go back to um
midas dutch exclusive footage of kevin
mccarthy
run run kevin run
run kevin run
there's one i want to see i think it was
treva trevor noah the daily show that
posted it where is it where is it
there's billy baldwins uh here it is
this is [ __ ] hilarious are you ready
if you haven't seen this yet you're in
for a treat
here's the daily show's version
[Music]
for all the audience listening out there
you know exactly what's going on you
didn't have to guess you didn't have to
watch you didn't have to go to youtube
what is he showing us i can only hear
now you know that's from the um
the gay mario brothers
when they get the star you know you get
to be really fast
and you're invincible at that point i
think that's the point that the daily
show was trying to make also we'll try
to get to the trevor noah third we're 40
minutes into the second hour so we got
about 20 minutes left we'll try to make
it to the statement that trevor noah
made about
joe rogan speaking of joe rogan earlier
there was another
oh there was another video there was
another video there was another video
that someone posted of course this is
all rachel's video that i just posted
here
some other people did some spoofs of
course the uh the the spoof
the spoof is what is this
what is this this is um this is
questioning by someone else let's watch
this
run
oh
[Laughter]
yeah i called for those people you've
said from the very beginning
should be in jail what they were talking
about is the six rnc members look at
this motherfucker's cheap ass suit
yeah you see the stitching on it you see
that
what the [ __ ] kind of cheap ass shoot is
this
this is like a dollar storage suit or
something look at this
i'm not i'm not trying to be you know
nitpicky here but look at this
what is that
come on i i i don't wear suits that
often i haven't wore suits that much of
my life but look at this [ __ ] guy
cough
yeah
look at that look at this look at this
what the [ __ ] is this
what the [ __ ] is this
has anyone anyone seen the suit here how
cheap this is
apparently kevin mccarthy isn't fast
enough to get
to to get any kind of a good suit
yeah dollar store suitage yeah it's like
a dollar store suit man what is this
i'm dead serious
this guy's the [ __ ] minority leader
of the house and he can't afford a
decent [ __ ] suit you kidding me
oh my god look here look here his team i
mean here i'm gonna go forward
look his team standing next to him and
number one they got a [ __ ] mask on
that's probably secure that's probably
secured yep it is see she's got the the
headphone piece here
this guy
now this is a decent [ __ ] suit look
at this guy let's see yeah well
look that's a decent [ __ ] suit right
there and the guy's got a [ __ ] mask
on he ain't rude
kevin mccarthy's coughing all over buddy
this [ __ ] disease around
coughing on everybody this guy's got a
nice [ __ ] clean suit it's not this
dollar store [ __ ] that old kevi's
got on here
oh kib
you got a [ __ ] mask on he's being
respectful that's a lot members who
january 6th yeah who weren't even here
who were in florida that day so your
support of that resolution yeah see it
doesn't matter if they're in florida or
not and really actually it probably does
matter that they're in florida that they
were trying to not be at an event as to
try to say oh i got an alibi i wasn't
there on january 6. i only tried to plan
the cheeto dust kangaroo i didn't try to
attempt it
i'm just part of the conspiracy
for [ __ ] sake series is who thinks
kevin mccarthy is a cowardly [ __ ] bag
have thought that for a long [ __ ]
time
i don't understand why he's still the
minority leader after he did the whole
hillary clinton benghazi thing you
remember that [ __ ]
now what's when joe's got posterior
kevin mccarthy ran away from the
reporter so fast he'd think she was
trying to have some legitimate political
discourse
oh
oh [ __ ]
legitimate political discourse
scared of words they are scared of words
aren't they they're just snow flaky
scared of words
so this is
this is kevin maul here's mine as dutch
run kevin run
here's their version and we've seen
we've seen the daily show's version
let's play this
[Music]
of course you could probably put 100
songs and 100 sounds to this thing and
it would all be fantastic it would all
be fantastic
oh [ __ ] kevin kevin kevin can't answer a
simple [ __ ] question can't answer a
simple [ __ ] question do you believe
that it is legitimate political
discourse like we're gonna have some
legitimate political discourse right
here in the hallway do you believe that
it's legitimate political discourse and
he just [ __ ] dashes
he's like get the [ __ ] out of here run
cough whatever you can do to hide it up
no we don't want to do that
okay
let's go to the uh trevor noah let's go
to that
because trevor noah was trending earlier
and i think
it was because
of his response to joe rogan i have not
watched it
i have not seen this but we'll go to the
thread here and we will we will try and
find the video find the footage we'll
find the footage here
because that's what we do on the [ __ ]
list roundup we ran up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends uh tuck
trump says uh here it's a huffington
post article uh trevor noah pats pence
on the back for trying new things
trying new things let's try some new
[ __ ] now you guys know that um mike
pence basically told
trump to go [ __ ] himself and then he's a
goddamn loser i mean he didn't say those
words but he pretty much aimed me called
him an american basically said you lost
[ __ ]
get over it you lost [ __ ]
but here is joe here's his um it looks
like his statements to joe rogan about
planet of the apes let's see
yeah and this is the daily show account
so we'll play it off here now they're
probably going to ding me on this
because they own this the daily show and
comedy center on this so they're
probably if if we play this video later
on in the week this part will probably
be silence when i show this video but
here we go even though rogan apologized
um this was strange a lot of people were
arguing sort of against his apology
saying that the n-word with context is
totally fine for a white person to say
yeah you know and i i i understand what
they so so uh you know that was the
right of the argument and that's what we
were saying earlier
with me and gabe is that these people
think that if you if you just change the
context that maybe that word's okay
which it may or may not be but that's
not the point because really honestly if
you look at joe rogan's word inside the
context it's racist as [ __ ]
they're saying like you know maybe
you're a professor teaching history
maybe you're a news anchor reporting on
a story
maybe you're in a quentin tarantino
movie and you have to use the n-word
because if you don't then the movie has
no dialogue
he makes he makes a decent point there
the quentin tarantino
definitely ratchets up the temperature
in a movie yeah of course quentin
tarantino has been
has been slammed for that for years uh
and then the actors have stood up for
him and that sort of thing and it's in a
script so you know that that i i guess
maybe that's a discussion you can have
about rather that rather that [ __ ]
words should be in those movies it's the
same discussion you you could have about
the the book to kill a mockingbird or
the adventures of huckleberry finn right
but
but
for the most part as a white person
you never need to use the n-word it's
not like need for example i've gone this
entire story saying the n-word and
everyone has understood exactly what
i've meant
exactly
exactly
they're all just sounds right it's
sounds
right and words are sounds but you know
it's it's the [ __ ] let's go brand and
[ __ ] too
sometimes we can't say what we want to
say so we say other things as humans all
right
nobody's sitting at home going nutella
neanderthal
nelly furtado why is trevor being so
vague what is the word in fact here's a
here's a life hack for white people
saying the actual n-word
puts you in unnecessary trouble
especially if you're not racist it
doesn't matter the context because black
people don't have the time to sit down
and sort out the racist who says the
n-word 70 times with the non-racist who
says the n word 70 times what a great
point
what a great point because white people
do this thing why people do this look
look around thing like when they're
going to tell a certain joke or they're
going to say something you know that
they they know if someone within earshot
of what what trevor is saying here
because
um you know and white people know this
so they do the
they look around before they say what
they're gonna say
and it's a it's a great point black
people are dealing with too much [ __ ] no
no look look at how i was using it
no one's got the time for that just stop
saying it or just be racist that's right
it's easy
so look and i'm with trevor on this just
be racist if you want to be racist just
be [ __ ] racist just say it out loud
you know what i was so disappointed in
is that is that donald trump just didn't
come out and say the word
that these these people don't just get
in front of a microphone and say the
word so we know for sure
like context or no context we know for
sure
who you are
and a little bit of that is the silver
lining behind trump is now we know who
these people are i'm glad i'm glad that
joe rogan has gone you know what i don't
i didn't need to use that word all those
times because people need to learn and
i'm glad that he has
right so joe rogan is saying that him
using the word in context wasn't racist
but it was ignorant and not cool okay
fine but don't forget
there's also the story
where joe rogan calls black people apes
and this and this is this is part of the
video
um that he's going to point out here
this is this is not something that like
someone secretly recorded joe rogan
saying
right this story that he's about to show
and i don't know if trevor's gonna show
it here but this is the story
um where he's going to see the movie
playing into the apes
joe rogan not only [ __ ] recorded it
edit it and then publish the [ __ ] for
people to hear him saying it
okay
he published it he wanted people to hear
himself say this story to tell the story
and so for that part of the apology
joe rogan says this
i did not nor would i ever
say that black people are apes but it
sure [ __ ] sounded like that i was
just saying there's a lot of black
people there but then i went on to talk
about what a positive experience it was
and how much
oh well well and i'm sure trevor is
going to do much better job than me here
but oh well well that makes it great
fun it was to go to see this movie in a
black neighborhood it wasn't a racist
story but it sounded terrible it's a
[ __ ] idiotic thing to say
and i was just trying to be entertaining
i certainly wasn't trying to be racist
see it's just it's this hiding behind
comedy thing right and and joe rogan for
all intents and purposes and parts of
his commentary he is a comedian he does
stand up but when he's talking in front
of microphones like that it's not always
comedy and people aren't taking it as
comedy they're taking into serious
commentary
right now we use comedy on this show to
keep your attention and make you
entertained so that you tune in
that we do it we'll admit to it
but work what we're doing is giving
serious political commentary i'm not
[ __ ] around
i'm dead serious about the [ __ ] i say
now yeah i mean obviously we use comedy
and we exaggerate when we're using
comedy but the commentary in and of
itself it's about serious [ __ ]
subjects serious [ __ ] things yeah i
caught the [ __ ] list roundup and and we
go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
but it's serious [ __ ] real life [ __ ]
this affects [ __ ] human beings
i certainly
would never want to offend someone
for entertainment with something as
stupid as racism
all right i'm not gonna lie i have a few
issues with this part of the video first
of all he says he would never say black
people are apes but he said that right
he that's literally what he said if you
said you walked into a black place and
it was planet of the apes then you've
said that you said you can't be like i
didn't say you did say it which is
racist right
and it's not just racist like let's
let's be honest but it's not just right
that's like og racism that's like like
the original old school like that's on
the mount rushmore of racism you know
black people are apes it's right next to
burning crosses and then like every bugs
bunny cartoon from the 1940s
what i found particularly illuminating
is is when he says
i wasn't being racist
i was just being
entertaining no joe i think
you were using racism to be entertaining
that's right
you said what i'm saying i'm not saying
he's entertaining racist
that's what he's doing
he's there he's their jester right
that's the whole point that's why these
[ __ ] are calling the mizella's brothers
these stoolies and these [ __ ]
roganites
and committing death threats
is because he's entertaining them with
racism you were trying to offend black
people by the way but you knew that
offending black people would get a laugh
out of those white friends that you were
with
and please understand this understand
this guy i'm a comedian
right which you would know if i had a
live audience right now
it would be like oh probably the
greatest of all time
yeah but i am a comedian and i love
making jokes and i love hearing jokes
and i love i love all kinds of jokes
right i love safe jokes i like dark
jokes i like jokes but just because
something is a joke
doesn't mean it can't be something else
as well because a joke can be racist
right in fact a joke can be racist and
funny if you're telling it to the right
crowd it's no joke it's never for yeah
someone can find it funny but the laughs
don't mean that there's no racism think
of it this way think of this way if i
rob a bank
and i get busted i can't defend myself
by saying no guys i did it as a joke
yeah but you pistol whipped the bank
teller yeah but but i made a funny it
was funny
and he's going to make good points here
but i do want to say back to the point
that i was trying to make of joe rogan
being the jester is that that's what
he's doing and that's what spotify did
that's what i want people understand
about spotify because they're i i've
gotten some a little bit of heat saying
that i'm not gonna leave spotify i'm not
gonna de-platform myself and i really
don't give a [ __ ] if you don't like that
i d platform myself from spotify fine
whatever i don't give a [ __ ] that's my
choice it's just like it's spotify's
choice and joe rogan's choice to stay on
spotify it's completely their choice i
mean i i know trevor here probably i i
know they have a podcast it probably
goes on spotify too and here he is here
he is bashing rogan so they had to make
a choice whether they're gonna stay on
spotify or not and it really is shitty
that we have to make those choices but
that's what we have to do
but i feel like i'm not talking and i'm
not [ __ ] and making entertainment
right
for racist
the racists aren't tuning in here
being like oh tony's really funny oh
he's so great
he says all the things i want to hear no
that's not what they're doing i mean if
they came here they wouldn't get they
wouldn't get a load of that
i mean we have people here that disagree
with me
that are in the comments we have people
that i have people that comment all the
time that disagree with me politically a
lot of times their political arguments
are thin you know they're like oh you
wear a backwards hat cool like okay yeah
but not much of an argument against my
political beliefs but yeah you know i i
look like i'm fred durst from the 90s
sure great okay great great comeback
on how to fix education in the country
fantastic we know now
why we need to fix education because of
comments like that
but they don't get up in my [ __ ]
comments and say racist [ __ ]
they don't because i'm [ __ ] white
because i'm [ __ ] white they don't say
racist [ __ ] to me
i mean i've got the whole race trader
thing before but they don't even do that
much
it's because i'm white
it's because the audience that joe rogan
placates to and he's entertaining are a
bunch of [ __ ] fragile male white
racist
that's what it is that's who the
audience is that's who spotify purchased
spotify doesn't give a [ __ ] about rogan
everyone thinks he's they're trying to
protect rogan they don't give a [ __ ]
about rogan
rogan's just the token to their [ __ ]
atm
don't you get it it's capitalism spotify
would put someone else in his place and
pay them a hundred million dollars if
they knew they could sell advertising to
that racist [ __ ]
that racist [ __ ] audience
and that's where some people had the
problem with spotify and i'm fine with
that i'm fine that you have that problem
with spotify and you should do what you
want to do
just like i'm going to do what i want to
do and and do it in the way that i'm
going to do it i'm going to keep yelling
in this microphone and i'll call spotify
out hell this podcast is on spotify
they're trying to placate the rogan's
racist
audience
now rather joe rogan intentionally did
that or not but over the years joe rogan
has developed and built a huge [ __ ]
white male fragile [ __ ] macho
machismo racist
[ __ ]
maga type trump type audience that's
what he's done that's what spotify
bought they bought the exclusive rights
to pump ads to that audience
and that is probably the best argument
for someone to take their take their
[ __ ] subscription and tell spotify to
go [ __ ] themselves
that's probably the best argument is
that spotify is placating to not joe
rogan
but his [ __ ] racist audience
he sound when i did it i was like
give me the money [ __ ]
so do i get to go now so yeah joe rogan
is saying that he would never say
something racist
and now because of that obviously in the
video a lot of his fans are like yeah he
would never say something racist it's
just a joke you guys are uptight he
would never say something racist a joke
is not racist and you know what i can
have my opinion
and you can have your opinion fine
but you know whose opinion i think
matches more than most people
is joe rogan
and here's what joe rogan said about his
joke when he said it
we walk into planet of the apes
we walked into africa dude
we we walked in the door and there was
no white people there was no white
people we planted the eggs didn't take
place in africa that was a racist thing
yeah exactly it is a racist thing for
you to say you're saying it's racist but
then in the video you're gonna be like
joe rogan said a racist thing and then
immediately acknowledge that it was
racist literally when he said it he said
it and then he's like wow that was
racist and now he's like i would never
never say racist like
you know this whole thing makes me go
like why are people so adamant
that it wasn't racist
like why do people people do a thing
that's racist and then they go like no
it's not race can i can i be honest with
you honestly i'm not a scholar i'm not
like the whatever this is my opinion i
think it's because people are just truly
petrified of having the label racist
branded on them for life that's what
people are really afraid of no one wants
to be called a racist because then
they're like how long am i a racist for
does it like am i racist for life am i
racist i can't get jobs am i right no no
i just want to be racist but i don't
want to be called a racist which is
understandable
but it also makes people unable to admit
when they say or do something racist
right they would rather down the hill of
them not being racist even if it means
giving convoluted excuses that don't
make any sense
it's a great great clip from trevor
trevor
thank you trevor
for explaining that um
from your from his perspective and you
gotta remember uh trevor noah
is not from america he's from south
africa so he is seeing different styles
and a different dichotomy of racism
altogether um than what we have seen in
this country i mean it's it you know it
it's it's a it was a completely
different world because um he's he's a
mixed race and he lived under apartheid
and then not under apartheid um so he
has a unique perspective i think uh in
racism in and of itself not just in this
country but
racism in general so i appreciate trevor
speaking up and and giving the world his
view on why joe rogan is racist after
joe rogan
called himself said oh that's what i
just said was racist
so
thank you very much trevor okay
we are we are past the second hour that
trevor noah's stuff um took us in all
the way to the end i appreciate trevor
verde again
we may have to silence the video youtube
may cut us off
this fair use thing is kind of a touchy
you know like how much you play what is
is it actual commentary or are you
commentating on commentary you know is
it is trevor noah a news story so
there's a lot of there's a lot of gray
area but there's a lot of
fences up for for fair use
when when we're um looking at stuff for
the dcma but um so if if that does get
silenced
you just have to go watch the video and
draw your own conclusions
i guess you know that or maybe i'll cut
it out maybe that's what i'll do is i'll
cut it out put it in its own video let
them silence that video
and then when um
or to keep that video up
because a lot of times they don't they
don't just like silence it right so like
i got a choice like on youtube they're
like uh do you want to silence this part
or do you want to give up your ad
dollars which i don't have enough
subscribers and enough viewers i mean
we're getting there we're getting there
let me go go subscribe to the youtube
channel because that that's going to
help us out
um but we we we got to get to a thousand
subscribers which i think we're over 900
today we got to get to a thousand
subscribers and that kind of stuff
before we
before we're able to
do the whole
uh
you know advertising thing
but they they won't let you monetize a
video that isn't yours right so that's
the thing
so maybe we'll work around and like i
liked uh um today
commenting on trevor's
video
so uh follow us again on on on twitter
at tony tony michael's pod at tony
michael at the tony michaels and i am
gabe sanchez go over and vote
for the bonehead of the week
now your choices this week are brian
suave uh forrest gump i mean uh
republican uh minority leader kevin
mccarthy and jared
kushner so go go go over there and take
your vote
on the bone end of the week and we'll do
that at the end of the week on friday
second hour we'll do bonehead of the
week we'll explain that
tomorrow i'm hoping tomorrow we have uh
our interview with jojo from jurors you
guys know jojo from jurors uh we did an
interview with her gabe should have that
cut tomorrow and hopefully we'll be able
to air that tomorrow so you guys can uh
listen to joe explain
explain her twitter account and how it
came to be and why she thinks her voice
is important and why your voice is
important ready
whether you have 200 followers or 200
000 over 200 000 like joe has your voice
is important uh pro-democracy causes and
to save
our democracy because we have to stay
pissed we have to go [ __ ] vote we
have to use some strategic outrage one
of those points of strategic outrage is
to draw wedges in between these
republicans
and you should be doing that right now
today as we speak going drawing wedges
between
mitch mcconnell and donald trump and
keep doing it
and until tomorrow at noon eastern 11
central surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking